I have in my company someone who knows
all about bulls flying in the back of
the net because he stopped most of them
he stopped most of them ever doing it
the greatest goalkeeper to ever grace
together football in the world by num
Arsenal Legend England Legend David
safehand Steven what an honor to have
the great man with me David welcome to
you and from uh uh Qatar Liverpool
former Liverpool manager calls Grand
souness and a presenter from the United
stand podcast Adam Scott who already
looks like he's throwing daggers at me
it's going to be a lively encounter with
him about what he thinks has happened to
his Club following this uh Ronaldo with
you can I get him to thank Cristiano by
the end for getting rid of the glazes
it'll be a tough gig but we'll see how
we get on
um let me start with you David
I don't want to talk about armbands I'm
done with armbands I've said my bit
about that I want to talk to you about
Cristiano Ronaldo because it is the
dominant story in World sport it's a
donkey sorry it's a dominant thank you
see you see immediately he immediately
catches it do you see the way you smoked
it was you that dropped this is why
these legends never lose it unbelievable
I just tested him look at that nobody
swept and put it back on that's what
he's going to say about it
um it's interesting you play with some
great players yeah you know from Dennis
birkam to others
what let's start from the interview
itself if you've been in a dressing room
one of the top players Thierry Omri
Dennis Bergkamp Tony Adams if one of
them had come out and done this
an interview like this what would your
reaction have been I would be I would
applaud him because he's obviously he's
talking the truth and it's not the the
story a lot of this stuff that he came
out with wasn't stuff that we haven't
heard yeah you know we've heard a lot of
other experienced players moaning is
criticizing man united for for the way
that the ground is the way that the
training that it was really interesting
when he said about the training ground I
was really
I couldn't believe it that the trading
around at Carrington was the same as
when he left what was it 15 or so years
ago and that really shocked me um
because he you know Arsenal I go in
there every week now and and I see the
Improvement that they've done you know
they've had an 18 million pound refund
and he was comparing it to what he
experienced at Real Madrid and Juventus
exactly yeah he said they would evolve
all the time constant new technology new
diet new nutrition he wasn't having a
pop at the chefs at United so they pop
up the food they're all preparing he
couldn't believe that they were just
having the same stuff they were given 12
years before yeah and like I said that
shocked me and that that shouldn't be
happening and like you say he's been all
around the world and seen how everywhere
has progressed and then he comes back to
his beloved Man United
and nothing he has no regrets whatsoever
about doing the interview I mean I've
spoken to him throughout the week he's
absolutely happy he's glad he's got his
freedom he's glad he's over albeit he
still loves Manchester United as a club
and he loves the fans and he doesn't
want any ongoing issue with them and I
suspect they'll calm down every time I
did when Roy Keane did the same thing
yeah man united TV but should he have
done the interview do you think
I I would say yeah because he put his
side over you know there was a lot of
stuff in the interview that I saw that I
didn't know about I didn't know about
other way that he was being treated you
know the stuff that was going on there
ten hug you know the fact that you know
he you know it's taking for instance the
substitution when he refused to go on
you know as a footballer he should never
do that you know you've got you've got
to like say oh
he had reason the week before yeah you
know where he was he was told that I'm
not putting you on because I respect you
too yeah so next week he's thinking well
he no longer respects me otherwise
nobody want me to come on I want to play
a clip before getting Graham's sooner so
this is a Roy Keane today it was the
first time he's had a chance to address
Ronaldo leaving United listen to what he
said
obviously the uh the interview was a
Tipping Point for him but I
that's it you know like because our man
united a great Club Ronaldo's a great
player as you said it's like a divorce
like the end of a relationship
we don't know how that feels and you go
your separate ways Life Goes On great
great player for Man United should have
probably left in the summer yeah but
that's the player's fault or the clubs
it was never going to happen the new
manager was never going to play him
he cannot have Ronaldo there's a sober
Fringe player he's just
it's just not right it's just not right
and it's it's it's sad
but these things happen
Sooners thank you very much indeed for
joining me again obviously this is a
fast-moving story and things have moved
on again from when we last spoke
Ronaldo's now gone glazes may be selling
up pretty tumultuous stuff over at
United but when you listen to what Roy
Keane said there
I I mean that to me I think he's right
about you know this stuff happens and
it's time to move on what did he say
Pierce
are you saying you sat on the fence a
bit
yeah I think which is very unusual for a
ride yeah he sat there and and said that
he's a great pillar he's been a great
servant and um
not a lot else he did go on to say that
he felt that he'd be mismanaged Ronaldo
which is kind of what you've said as
well about this but now that's all I
would say I would say I would say
I would certainly agree with that my
take is the same take on it as the exact
same as when we spoke before when I was
on your show I think
the two of them got together when
Ronaldo stated he wanted to leave in the
summer the two of them go in a room with
him and the manager they come out that
room two people leave the room and two
of them are satisfied with what they've
agreed
the lose to Brighton the lose to
Brentford and all of a sudden is chaos
at man united I think the manager
panicked his coaching staff panicked we
need not so much of a victim but we need
to analyze where we're going wrong I
think they've come up with the wrong
analysis I think they've looked at we
can't press with Ronaldo and our team
now my take on it as a football person I
don't believe Ronaldo
even in 37 I don't think man united can
be doing without Ronaldo at this time in
their development where they want to be
I think it's been a
an enormous case of
mismanagement I think it's an enormous
case of lack of
speaking to each other communication
if the manager and the staff have
decided after two games because I've
lost two games
we're going to go a different route
after having agreed with Ronaldo before
any games are played they had to
communicate that to Ronaldo because what
happened after that was you've you've
touched already
they don't bring them on against Man
City that's come to go on against
Tottenham a week after that or 10 days
after that that's going to be Captain
they are really mixed messages for a
player to accept yeah and when the word
disrespect was used by Ronaldo I think
that's saying that someone has gone back
on their words and who can it be it can
only be the man united manager right he
has changed whatever he said before a
ball was kicked so where he got to the
situation where he came out and made his
statement with you disrespect I think
someone's not someone's changed their
minds on it yeah I think you're right
well let's go to Adam's stop uh
presenter of the United States and I
think that's where anger comes from
right Pierce I have to say that I think
the stuff about swimming pools and
kitchen
that really doesn't come into the
argument why he's leaving man united
he's leaving man united because he still
feels he's a football nut we know that
yeah look at him he's a specimen there
is not out there and I've said this
again there's out there there's not a
better example you could have in your
dressing room surely you want to keep
that man united are a country mile away
from where they need to be is it you
know the great football club that they
are they ain't going to be winning the
European the Champions League anytime
soon they will not be winning the
Premier League anytime soon Ronaldo is a
role model you'd have to explain this to
him I want you here because this that
and that him is a role model you could
not name me a better one in the history
of football right not in this generation
in the history of football yeah for me I
would have thought to keep them I would
have pleaded with them to stay because I
need you if you're a young fella in that
dressing room
prior to Ronaldo turning up
who do you look at an address room and
say in 10 years time I want to be like
him so Ronaldo turns up everyone in the
dressroom says in 10 years time I want
to be like him I think it's a girl I
think it's a mistake and letting them go
but time will tell interesting stuff uh
Graham thank you let's go to Adam stop
well Adam look don't listen to what I
have to say about this I'm an Arsenal
fan I don't really care how tumultuous
things get at United but I'm also an
interviewer and I sat with Ronaldo and
he gave me his side in his eyes he was
correcting a lot of untruths that have
been said about him so it was more a
repost if you like or a bottle of a lot
of things
um as a United fan what's your feeling
about all this
yeah I mean I look at them listening to
what Graham said there at the start of
the season and Ronaldo in your interview
Pierce went on about the start of the
Season no free season was why and he
understood why he didn't start the
season but in the Brighton game he
played 37 minutes the Brentford game he
played the full nine set we lost both of
them games it wasn't a knee-jerk
reaction we just went back to basics 10
hag went to the training ground and
fought up a different plan Ronaldo
didn't start the next four games the
next four games Manchester United won
and turned their season around a manager
has to make a decision for the better of
the team and if that doesn't involve
Cristiano Ronaldo at that time then
that's down on the manager and it worked
for the manager people will be in over
the top with 10 hacks team selection for
the Liverpool game I remember talking to
Graham sunes just on the eve of that
game with the protests and Graham
student has fought that the protest
would be a hindrance on Manchester
United going into that game it didn't it
the crowd came to together and they got
behind the team and that team didn't
have Cristiano Ronaldo in it the fans
got behind whoever was on that picture
wanted to give 100 and there is a
general consensus we're in the united
fan base Ronaldo hasn't been giving that
100 whether that be for his opinion on
how he's been treated the fans are
seeing what's going on the pitch more we
don't see everything on behind the
scenes obviously but what counts is what
happens on the pitch and he hasn't been
performing this season in particular and
the team is playing better without
Ronaldo
you say that
I'm in a blissful position of Arsenal
being top of the league by five points
and and 11 points clearer of United
you've got to go to the playoffs now
against Barcelona beat you without
Ronaldo right you got to get to the
playoffs against Barcelona Europa League
which you may lose
um I'm not quite sure this constitutes a
great Revolution so far ten hog is
completely unproven outside of Holland
and I might the point that Graham made
which really resonated with me and I
think I know the answer is that if
you're in that dressing on why wouldn't
you see him as the greatest role model
has ever been actually one of the big
big concerns Ronaldo had was unlike him
when he walked into that dress room as
an 18 year old and saw skulls and gigs
and keen and Ferdinand and wanted to
soak all he could off them in terms of
experience and expertise a lot of these
young United players earn too much money
and don't care and didn't really want to
do that with him I found that staggering
yeah no I can understand that side of it
and when Ronaldo did that interview one
of the many few he did last season
saying that the younger player didn't
want to take his advice I was fully on
board with that the problem that we've
had with Ronaldo is the fact we didn't
think he should have done the interview
with yourself person the way it was he
was on the contracts at Manchester
United he talked about the times have
changed since Relic Ferguson left the
football club I guarantee he wouldn't
have done this interview with yourself
if Alex Ferguson was still manager of
the football club it's the it's what
we've seen as like going behind the
manager's back the fans support the
manager we support the manager he's the
biggest man at this football club famous
words that came out of Alex Ferguson's
mouth and that's who the fans will be
behind well you're supporting him
the team you'll support him until you
get rid of him like the last few you've
had I mean let's be honest every manager
since Ferguson has had your Universal
support United fans right to the point
they've been slung out that's been part
of the problem
um but look uh Graham you've been
shaking your head listening to of this
do you want to respond no no I I sorry
what's this what's the chapter the
United States
hi Adam Adam I think you know what what
you what you said a lot of it is correct
it's a manager it's a manager's decision
to to go to a different route if he
feels his his team are not at it it's
not working his game plan but where I'm
coming from
I think he has to communicate that to
Ronaldo listen we had that conversation
I think that's the word disrespect
sticks in my head yeah that's saying
someone by Dieter words is not carried
carried through and what they're either
going to do or say and I think they had
an agreement two games later the manager
has changed and gone down a different
route that that is a manager's
prerogative but I think at that time
it's not been from that I said looking
and I don't know anything that's not
being communicated
to Ronaldo because if I had been
communicated to Ronaldo I don't think
the word disrespect would come out and I
and I and I and I think
you said you turned the season round I
think turned around from the first two
games that you lost picked up a few
points but I I've been in dressing rooms
I I constantly see on on what I'm on
television that you cannot be successful
as a manager of stock coach unless
you've got good senior Pros that is a
fact of life as I see it and I think as
born if you look at the clubs that have
been successful you look at your Club
over the years is a perfect example yeah
it keeps Gary Neville a couple years
I'm going to go and have dinner with
them after this
it kept going over maybe two years long
two years longer than he should have
done
Paul scholes left and brought him back
he kept getting Ryan Giggs onto his
about 35-36 because he had good senior
Pros we made sure people turned up on
time to improperly they're at every day
in training and their attitude to games
when it mattered you need good senior
pros and I come back to it you could not
get a better example of a good Senior
Pro than Ronaldo yeah and also when when
when
he was sent to chamber the kids the word
is he was now on perfect the way he
trained with the kids I heard that so I
come back to you cannot have enough good
senior Pros Graham I've gotta I'm gonna
leave it there Adam thank you very much
indeed I appreciate it uh final word to
you David
um last night I was sitting next to you
when news broke that Ronaldo was now
available yep and your immediate
reaction
was or we should take him [ __ ] the
rest of the season totally I was like
we'd have him and we both agreed I
totally agree I even like listened to
Graham there you know he's talking about
Ronaldo he's not he's not done he's far
from done you know we actually need a
good natural history goal it'd be
perfect for Arsenal you know and he'd be
perfect a lot over the clubs yes you
know where he gets the respect yeah but
you never heard any players moaning
about Alex or Alex Ferguson no about a
lack of respect no absolutely right
we're going to leave you David Seaman
with the replay if you're brilliant save
of my pen let's have a look at this
instant I mean it was so fast
David great to see you really appreciate
it